NARRATOR: In the Blue Ridge
Mountains, with cash in hand,
Eustace is finally ready to make
his down payment on the land
next door.
EUSTACE: Feels really
good to get this last bit.
I've been struggling so
hard so long all winter
long just to get
this down payment.
Now I've got it.
NARRATOR: He spent
three decades building
Turtle Island into
a sanctuary, hidden
away from the outside world.
Now to protect it, he's
racing to beat the competing
bidder to the punch.
EUSTACE: I'm heading
straight over to Ronnie's
cause I've got to get this
down payment in his hands.
Because I'm just really afraid
somebody else might get it.
I can't have that.
What you say, Ronnie?
Hey how are you
doing, Eustace?
EUSTACE: Doing all right.
Good to see you.
Good, man.
Man, you got a nice
spot for a garden here.
RONNIE: Thank you.
EUSTACE: That's like a million
dollar view right there.
Beautiful, ain't it?
EUSTACE: Yeah buddy.
Speaking of money, I
brought you something.
I appreciate you
writing me that letter.
You haven't sold
it yet, have you?
RONNIE: No.
Man I'm glad you showed up.
EUSTACE: Well thank you.
And it's just real nice sort of
like sense of relief like, OK.
It's happening.
I'm doing it.
I got the money.
I'm handing it off.
The land is secure
as long as I can
keep going with the payments.
RONNIE: So since we last
spoke, you really been working,
ain't you?
EUSTACE: Oh my gosh.
I've been selling hogs,
cutting trees for people,
milling lumber, selling lumber.
Here's what I got
to show for it.
I got the deposit here.
RONNIE: Wow.
Well thank you, man.
You're a man of your word.
EUSTACE: Yeah buddy.
NARRATOR: The $30,000 payment
earmarks the land for Eustace.
But he will fully own it until
he's paid off the balance.
RONNIE: I'm glad to
have you getting it.
We'll keep that land wild.
RONNIE: Yes sir.
NARRATOR: It's a process that
will take years of hard work.
But it's a small price to pay
for the freedom to live free.
Thank you again.
I really appreciate you.
Yes sir, Eustace.
See you around, buddy.
EUSTACE: All right.
Take care.
To me, there's a way too much
over development in this world.
And I want to do at least my
part in keeping some of it
wild.
NARRATOR: As dawn breaks over
the Blue Ridge Mountains,
Eustace begins a new
chapter at Turtle Island
by paying his respects
to its fallen forefather.
Well buddy, I
secured that land.
Yeah, we're going
to keep it wild.
I knew you'd appreciate that.
Preston and I all of our life
have enjoyed the wild land.
And it's just a commitment we've
had in our entire adult life
to try to keep some of it clean
and wild, preserved, taken care
of so that future
generations can enjoy it,
and even just like, see
what wild land looks like.
And so here's one more piece.
And I'm carrying
on the tradition
and keeping the
commitment and I feel
good about that achievement.
It's been hard without you.
We're keeping it
going best we can.
Your son's been helping me out.
Joseph, James,
Travis, all helping.
I appreciate you being
here with us in spirit.
I'm missing Preston terribly.
But he wouldn't
want me to give up.
So I'm just going to
try to do the best
I can to honor our friendship.
If I want to survive,
I got to keep going.
So I'm just going to
keep forward thinking
and forward momentum
and hopefully, we'll
just keep going with
this vision and plan
and see it through til it works.